reunión de crisis en bruselas los
ministros europeos de energía acordaron
el viernes medidas de emergencia para
frenar la subida de los precios del gas
y la electricidad
provocada por la ofensiva rusa en
ucrania
la solidaridad y la cooperación de la
unión europea deben seguir estando en el
centro de nuestras acciones así nos
aseguraremos de que las manipulaciones
de vladimir putin y su guerra del gas
fracasen desde el cierre total del nord
stream 1 el gas ruso representa ahora
sólo el 9 por ciento de las
importaciones europeas frente al 40 por
ciento de antes de la guerra
oficialmente rusia afirma que se debe a
problemas de bombeo relacionados con las
sanciones occidentales y no a medidas de
represalia ya se han adoptado varias
propuestas para hacer frente a la crisis
energética
en primer lugar limitar temporalmente el
precio pagado a rusia por sus entregas
de gas a la unión europea para reducir
aún más los ingresos del kremlin que
financia la guerra en ucrania segundo
pedir a las grandes empresas energéticas
que se metan la mano al bolsillo los 27
proponen limitar los ingresos de los
productores de electricidad
al mismo tiempo tomar una parte de los
beneficios de los grupos de gas petróleo
y carbón en forma de impuestos europeos
darius la limitación de los ingresos de
los productores de electricidad de bajo
coste y la creación de una contribución
solidaria para las empresas productores
de combustibles fósiles this will
limitarán el impacto de los unidos de
precios a los consumidores
price es un costo más los 27 quieren
unir fuerzas para presionar a rusia
mientras vladimir putin amenaza con
cerrar definitivamente el grifo del gas
a europa